All right, so this week we're talking about morality now it might seem on the surface
That's to talk about morality is pretty straightforward, right? It's right versus wrong
It's what we should be doing what we shouldn't be doing and we're really comparing that all to God as the standard
So it seems pretty straightforward seems pretty simple
I mean, but I want you to take a second and step back because it may not be as
Simple as you think or as you hope because I want you to think for a minute about really what we're asking students to do
We're asking them to differentiate between right and wrong
And we're asking them to do that when they're taught that some of these things that we're talking about are
Just a little bit more than mere opinion
See students are taught on a whole different level than maybe what we're used to so you're
Experience something that maybe you don't realize you're gonna experience when you we stand on stage as
Leaders and we're talking about Jesus and we're talking about you know truth and we're talking about these these
Fundamental facts about the Christian faith and we're telling them what they ought to be doing what they ought not to be doing
Students can often be looking at us as we're thinking we're talking about fact
We're thinking we're talking pretty black and white kind of things and that may not necessarily be the case
When some of our students are looking up to us and thinking well, that's your opinion
That's what you think and I'm not sure if I actually want to agree with your opinion
So this is a good week. It's a good time
To take a step back
Make sure you meet with your small group leaders and make sure you talk through a little bit about what they might
experience in their small groups and
Talk a little bit about some feedback that you know
You can get from the students about some of the things that you're talking about from the main stage
About what their thoughts are on right versus wrong and what they're being taught in school and how they feel about certain topics
You might be comforted
But you also might be surprised and you might get some answers that you're not real thrilled with
But it's a good starting point and something that you can continue to work through
So I'll never forget back when I was teaching I'd walk in in the morning
And you'd be stepping through the hallways
You have to literally step over all of the students that were sitting in the hallways and talking all these great
Conversations and activity going on the hallways
It was a great sort of experience in the morning to see some students smiling faces and other students
No, not so smiling faces and it was awesome and one day the teachers mean we got talking about some of the students and
We realized something that most of us just were completely blind to the students were doing more than just sitting in the hallways
Hanging out. Well, the students were sitting in the hallways
Copying each other's homework for their first class or their first couple of classes throughout the day and some of us talked about
Well, are they collaborating and working together on something or are they just straight up copying their homework, which would be obviously wrong
And so we talked about we debated it a little bit. Let me decide. Well, let's confront some of our students
Let's talk through with some of our students. Maybe they just don't realize what they're doing, which would seem strange
But maybe they don't realize what they're doing is wrong
So we pulled a few students aside with no intention of getting them in trouble and just said hey
What are you doing in the hallways in the morning?
And with no regard for you know, possibly getting in trouble or or having us to call our parents or
You know some kind of consequence coming down on them. They just were like, yeah, we're just copying homework
That's what we're doing. No big deal
And so we asked them like well, do you think this is wrong?
The response was simple. Well, no
Well, why not? Well, because we just don't that was their answer. They just don't
And if you do a little bit of research into the world of
Education and what students are being taught is right and wrong
It's actually becoming more and more closer to what we consider to be opinion
And students are being taught anytime we use words like
feeling or
What they believe it's more about what they think is simply an opinion
Well, this is sort of causing some problems, right?
Because now when we start talking about things more than just copying homework as being an opinion
When we say things like well are all men or all people created equally. Well, is that a fact or is that an opinion?
What about it's wrong in our country to drink under the age of 21 is that a fact or is that just an opinion of somebody?
What about killing another unjustly?
Something we all consider at least hope all consider to be a universal
Truth that killing another unjustly as in murder is wrong
Then is that fact or is that opinion?
So the slippery slope that the students are starting down is these things are necessarily becoming a little bit more based on
Opinion so then when we get into things like same-sex marriage
Fact or opinion
So as you stand on a main stage or you stand in front of a group of students and you start talking about what scripture says is fact
They are being taught that these things are often just opinion
So talking about morality is vitally vitally important in terms of helping them establish
What our moral compass actually is and where we get our morals from so a little story
I like to tell when it comes to morality
It's a story about little Johnny and little Johnny is this is a little first or second grader
That gets an assignment from school to go home and measure how tall he is
And you run fumbles around house and he trying to figure out how to measure himself
So you can go back to school and be a huge success and get a great grade and all those wonderful things
And scrambles all over the house and you can't figure out anything and finally he has this
massively beautifully wonderful idea
And he runs the school the next day and all the little boys and girls are
Going up to the front of the class and some say you know
I'm this tall according to my dad and I'm this many basketball is high and you know all these other different objects and Johnny
Gets up in front of the classroom and big smile beaming says I'm one Johnny tall and
The teacher you know kind of looks at him and serve reacts and Johnny didn't pass the assignment
Because Johnny has we have no idea how tall Johnny really is because Johnny will never be more or less than one Johnny
Tall no matter how big Johnny actually gets in the future. See we can't use
ourselves to measure
Ourselves we need something beyond us something external to us and morality functions the same way
And what's beautiful about morality as much as it's difficult to follow what God desires for us to do
The fact that we have morals the fact that we understand right from wrong
Helps us see who God is points us to God gives us evidence for God because we need something beyond ourselves to understand
What the difference between right and wrong is?
So what can we do right? So there's a lot of cautionary there
So what can you actually do? Well the first thing that you can do is approach all of this first and foremost with grace and with love
Remember most of your students
I hope all of your students really are just trying to love their friends and love the people and be tolerant and get
Along and and live peacefully among everybody else. I'm sure that's the case with almost all if not all of your students
So they're not trying to be malicious. They're not trying to necessarily defy authority
So approach them with a tremendous amount of grace and a tremendous amount of love and listen
Listen to the reasons that they're giving that doesn't mean don't challenge those reasons
But make sure that you thoroughly thoroughly listen to you know why they're saying what they're saying
Secondly know where they're coming from
Talk to them about where they're hearing their ideas, you know, which classes even which teachers is it at home?
Is it online? Is it TV and media? Where are they getting these ideas from now? That doesn't mean you don't want to tell them
Oh, your ideas are stupid
You would just want to hear where they're from and hear again
Why they believe those things and why they think those things are true and help them work through what those
Those those thoughts actually are no different than helping us
You know you guys working through all of these topics and answering great questions and asking more great questions and trying to figure things out
You want to help students navigate this a little bit rather than just shoot them down and finally don't be afraid to challenge their thinking
Some students might come at you a little bit some students might get a little bit aggressive might some might just shut down inside themselves if they feel like
Their opinion is not value or not being heard
That's okay as long as you draw that back out of them and don't get offended if a student kind of comes at you
Challenge their thinking but do so again in love and in understanding and by listening and taking the time necessary
And make sure that this is communicated to your small group leaders because in that context in that community in the community that you
Are trying to build within your youth groups
It is so so important that those students feel like they can open up and they feel like they can offer that opinion
And and be and be accepted but also be challenged